hey guys uh today i am back with another
video to talk about streaming um i
apologize in advance because much unlike
my chode uh this video is gonna be
pretty freaking long
um additionally the one other really
nice thing about this is that the second
we're done covering streaming we've
basically covered all like the
fundamental slash you know theoretical
topics so now from here on out we can
either basically look at specific
technologies or like even more in-depth
algorithms so
we're gonna start going from you know
systems design noobs to experts after
this video um either way let's get into
it like i said it's gonna be a long one
all right well stream processing what is
it
um as far as the background goes um like
batch processing there are often times
where we have data and we want to
perform some sort of computation on it
in the background however unlike batch
processing which takes a bounded set of
input files streaming works on an
unbounded set of data so we go ahead and
do that you know on messages as they
come in basically and then we process
them asynchronously
messages are going to be created by some
node in our system called a producer
that could be a server a client or
anything and then eventually it's going
to be handled hopefully by at least one
consumer node
and then finally even though these
messages can be sent directly from
producer to consumer via protocols like
udp multicast or something like that
generally speaking we tend to use an
intermediary such as a message broker in
order to buffer these messages in some
sort of centralized place or queue
so let's talk about those message
brokers because that's kind of the most
important concept of this video message
brokers are a special type of database
for streaming all they basically do is
allow producers and consumers to connect
to them the producers can push messages
to them and the consumers can go ahead
and automatically pull messages from
them
some keep those messages durably which
means that even after they've been sent
to a consumer they still stay in the
message broker and others don't they
just go ahead and delete them so there
are basically two delivery patterns for
a message broker
one is fan out which means every message
that's in the broker is going to be sent
to all consumers that are subscribed to
the broker
and there's also load balancing which is
basically saying in order to maximize
throughput and performance each one of
the consumers is going to only handle
one message in order to process as many
messages as we can at a time
okay what about sending messages in
order even though the messages are
represented by a cue which inherently
should hold those messages in a first in
first out order if a message takes
really long to process or if a consumer
fails while handling a message the
message broker generally is not going to
wait for an acknowledgement from the
consumer that it has properly handled a
message and will instead send out the
subsequent messages to other consumers
hence unless we take additional
precautions on our end which i'll
discuss later in the video generally
speaking we can assume that messages are
not going to be delivered or processed
in order
okay so there are two main types of
message brokers and i'll discuss them
both now the first is in memory so for
example if we have something like a
redis instance which is basically just a
database that allows you to write to
memory as opposed to disk
we can just go ahead and make a cue in
there and use our messages and you know
establish some sort of long polling with
a bunch of consumers
and then the second that a consumer
acknowledges that it's
processed a message that'll be deleted
the other type are log based message
brokers and i'll discuss those now but
the main point is that the messages are
held on disk in some sort of log
so what is a log based message broker
well basically every single message goes
to an append only log on disk which as
we know means the writes are going to be
pretty fast because we can just you know
do them sequentially additionally that
log can actually be partitioned and
replicated in order to ensure fault
tolerance obviously we don't want to be
losing any messages if our message
broker server goes down
and in addition the fact that it's
partitioned means that we can have
multiple consumers reading from each
partition and that way we can improve
parallelism and performance
generally speaking we do one consumer
per partition and the reason to do this
is that ensures that all the messages
are going to be handled in the proper
order per partition so that's important
to note which is that you know obviously
if we're load balancing our messages
between partition via some sort of like
consistent hashing method
um
then uh
it's not necessarily all going to be in
order but if you know we like smartly
distribute the messages per petition uh
we might be able to handle those in an
order that we want
another thing to note is the issue with
having one consumer per partition is
that one long uh message that you know
it takes a while to process is gonna
slow all the other messages um in that
partition down from being processed
because they have to wait for the slow
one
okay so actually representing this
visually as you can see we have these
two partitions in a log based message
broker and as you can see we have
a consumer reading each of them and the
producer based on some sort of hash
function can push a message to either of
these partition so on a right for
example let's say we're going to go and
write to the top partition
and
we'll say write m5 all we're going to
really do is use our hash function to
decide which partition the message is
going to be sent to and then go ahead
and append it to that write only log
okay in terms of reading a message as
you can see each consumer is keeping
track of which index that it is
currently read in the log what does this
do well it shows us which messages have
already been handled so if that consumer
fails we have the fault tolerance aspect
of saying okay we're not going to
accidentally
reprocess this message so that's really
useful but as you can see now that
consumer 2 is reading m7 it can go ahead
and say okay now we're on index 2 which
means the next message we should be
reading is m8
the second that the message broker
receives an acknowledgement by the
consumer that it successfully read a
message it's going to increment that
index
locally thus keeping track of how much
the consumers have read
okay so what's the ultimate comparison
between log based message brokers versus
in-memory message brokers well in-memory
message brokers are really good in terms
of their performance
messages if they take a long time to
process obviously you want them to be
written to and read from memory because
that's just faster rights than disk but
in addition when their order doesn't
matter and we just want to achieve
maximum throughput because say they you
know take a while to process
that would in a log-based message broker
be a real bottleneck because it means
that the partition can't move forward
until that message is processed so if
you just want to have a bunch of
consumers and achieve really fast
throughput in some arbitrary ordering of
the messages in memory is probably the
way to go for you
otherwise if you want to have some
durability of your messages maybe you
want to be able to replay them later or
take a look at them for debugging
purposes
or even just order them in some sense or
another then log based is probably the
way to go
okay so what are some common usages of
streams because right now i've kind of
just defined them as some arbitrary
things but uh let's give some examples
in order to help
you know show everyone what they're
actually useful for one way they're
hugely important is logging in metrics
when you're logging in an application we
don't really need to use the logs
generally speaking instantly or the
metrics instantly but it's good to be
able to look back on them do some
processing with them in order to make
you know metrics for say like a certain
time window
so logging in metrics we want to be able
to aggregate certain events into time
windows such as logs or you know maybe
like the load on our servers or
something like that and this is
challenging for a couple of reasons well
first of all are we talking about the
time that the message was received by
the message broker the time that um the
message was sent by the server and it's
kind of hard because like i've mentioned
in uh previous videos most server clocks
are out of sync and as a result of that
it's kind of hard to get over the
discrepancy of which time to actually
use the processing time so the time that
the event actually happened or the
receiving time which is the time that
the message broker actually got that
event
additionally what if say we want to find
all the events that happened from
you know one o'clock to two o'clock p.m
today and then we know that some event
that happened from one o'clock to two
o'clock p.m actually only shows up in
the message broker at 3 pm are we going
to you know add it to our window in
retrospect or should we just discard it
and accept that we have incomplete data
so you know these are all considerations
to make
in terms of how we might actually put
events in a fixed time interval well
i'll talk about three different types of
windows first they're tumbling windows
so there's going to be non-overlapping
intervals of fixed length so say um
every single minute starting at the
zeroth second um so like 1201 uh 1201 to
1202 1202 to 1203 1203 to 1204 and
they're not overlapping and they're all
one minute long so that's pretty easy to
do in terms of you know you just
actually
go ahead and aggregate all that data and
calculate it together however then
there's this thing called hopping
windows hopping windows are similar but
imagine it being like
12 o'clock to 1205 1201 to 1206 1202 to
1207 so there's overlap overlap between
them so what you should actually be
doing there is calculating the tumbling
window for every single minute and then
aggregating those to create a five
minute hopping window and then finally
there's also a concept of a sliding
window which doesn't necessarily have a
discrete or rather
you know one set start point and end
point but it's just a sliding window of
a fixed duration but it could start it
literally any time all we can really do
there is use an in-memory buffer of all
the events in the sliding window and
then probably have some secondary
processor thread that removes
events as soon as they're outside of
that time window and adds them as soon
as they're in the time window
okay now we also have this concept of
change data capture so this is a little
bit different than uh logging and
metrics but basically change data
capture is taking the write ahead lock
from any single database so imagine we
have like a single leader replication so
all of our writes are going to one
single database change data capture is
saying take our write ahead log and
don't only send it to the other replicas
but go ahead and stream it to other
sources of data that we also have to
keep up like our caches our search
indexes our data warehouses and as a
result we can actually process those
right ahead logs and update our other
sources of data to make sure that our
derived data is up to date
um assuming these logs are persistent
they can also be compacted from you know
getting too big assuming we're using
like a log base message broker by just
only keeping the most recent value of
any key
that's kind of similar to something we
did with uh indexes as well in our first
video
and then finally we have event sourcing
event sourcing at a surface level is
really similar to change data capture
but the subtle difference is this
instead of streaming changes made to a
database and kind of all of that stream
is represented as like hey what key did
we change you know what row
what we're actually going to be doing is
streaming the user events so a user
event might be something like you know
jordan clicks a watch button jordan is
the 40th watcher of some video so we're
not putting it in database terms but
we're putting it in terms of the actual
like front end of the application itself
and then what this does is it allows us
to derive a ton of different data
in basically any way we want we
basically just have to write application
code that says
here's how you should handle this event
for this database and what it does is it
doesn't leave us to having to deal with
one schema of data but rather we can
develop many different schemas of data
just because we have all of these events
and we can derive a ton of different
views of the data from it
okay now let's quickly talk about stream
joins if you watch the batch processing
episode there are batch processing joins
and this all basically comes from the
fact that there are associations within
the data
so more or less like with batches
we want to be able to do a ton of joins
here and there are three types that i'll
talk about so stream stream joins stream
table joins and also table table joins
so the first type stream stream joins
are basically when we're joining two
different types of events in a stream so
the example from ddia is this and
hopefully this will make sense imagine
i'm google
every time you type in the search bar i
want to see
for that search
which advertisements you've clicked and
you might click zero or
more advertisements so i can't just say
every single time there's a click log
the search that it came from because
then that doesn't show me the searches
where there were no clicks so basically
all we can really do is have all of our
search events in a stream have all of
our click events in a stream and then
you know try and join them based on this
concept of a session id that probably
relates to some sort of you know search
id so what you'll actually do is in each
stream you'll keep an index
of all of those searches or clicks for
both the search and the click stream and
then you'll cross-reference the other
streams index every time a new event
comes in to try and find an association
between the two
this local index is something that we'll
see a lot in both the other
in both the other types of joins for the
stream and it all comes down to having
to involve some sort of state in our own
stream so that we can um go ahead and
reduce the number of calls made to a
database or another stream
okay now we have this concept of stream
table joins where instead of joining two
streams together we have one stream and
we're probably trying to enrich an event
with some data from a database so we're
going to make a join on you know say a
few columns of a database
obviously it would be very problematic
if every single time a stream event came
in we had to make a very expensive
network call to a database so instead
what we do is we keep a local copy of
the database in the stream so we keep
some state there and then every single
time that database is updated we use
change data capture to keep the local
copy of our database and the stream
updated then we can actually perform the
join without having to do any network
calls
okay finally we have table table joins
this is basically saying um you know
imagine that we have two tables where um
every single time where there's a change
to them we frequently want to um go
ahead and take the joint of them
and
keep that join in like a kind of cached
way where you know say
we have like a tweets and followers
table
and we want to see for each tweet
which followers to send it out to so
every time there's a new tweet we want
to find all the followers for it
so a table table join can be done by
basically having two subscribers for the
change data capture of each table
and when that change data comes in you
go ahead and perform the join on
local copies of a stream
i know i probably didn't explain that in
the best way but hopefully it makes
sense
okay and then finally i know this keeps
going but we're almost done uh fault
tolerance so we want to ensure and this
is pretty important that each message is
processed exactly once and that means
not zero times not two times not three
times only once
so in order to mess in order to ensure
that each message is processed at least
once what can we do well we can
occasionally checkpoint the stream state
to disk so this is especially relevant
for in memory streams
um so that you know if something were to
crash we still have those messages that
are durable and they still get processed
at least once additionally if we have a
bunch of messages in memory we can run
them as micro batches so that basically
means like you run i don't know say 10
stream events as a batch job and if you
recall from the batch job video batch
jobs are really easy to restart if they
go wrong and that way we can ensure that
every single message is going to be
processed at least once
in order to make sure however that
messages are not
processed more than once we have a
couple of options we could use atomic
transactions so if you remember
two-phase commit
it basically involves a coordinator node
making sure that in this case it would
be that the message brokers both sends
the message to the consumer and the
consumer also processes it at the same
time so that's what two-phase commit
would do here however
that's really expensive and it also
isn't very fault tolerant because of a
coordinator node so a lot of people
prefer to use instead is this concept of
item potence which means that
you know we only allow an operation that
occurs to have an effect one time so you
know if it happens more than once there
will be no additional effect
and a way that this can be done for you
know a lot of streaming applications is
you use some sort of item potency key
which is basically just a unique user id
and then you have some sort of database
or system that checks if the user id has
been seen before and if it has you don't
process the message again and if it
hasn't you can go ahead and process it
okay in conclusion
streaming is becoming pretty important
because companies have tons of data that
they need to process in the background
and oftentimes it's not necessarily like
a batch job where it makes sense to
process it for a discrete time interval
but rather it's just better if you
process it as it comes in
um log base streams versus uh in memory
based streams have their advantages and
disadvantages where the log base streams
you know optimize for durability and
ordering while the in-memory streams
just optimize for throughput basically
and try and uh get all of those messages
out of the memory
oftentimes there is a need to do some
sort of joining or enriching of stream
data and as you can see we've covered
three methods of stream joins and that's
how you would go ahead and do that
and then finally
event sourcing and change data capture
offer interesting ways to kind of keep
up your derived data whether that's with
a search index or a cache or some other
data type
okay overall yeah guys
last video of just like the pretty basic
concepts to cover from here on out we're
going to be going pretty in depth and
personally i greatly look forward to
that so uh